is such a horrible makeup they like um  as soon as they start putting stuff on  their like you look good I go from like  my regular dumb face which in fat to  like sorry look deep into my eyes your  Brown is a version of hazel  makes mirror face thing sex it's pretty  I mean yeah pretty close I say very  [ __ ] I become the man I want to be  want to be you know like a real sex pot  well let's this game I don't know why I  wrote C and then s but I thought to g5  no mine is the hardest really because we  talked about earlier and you're in  service  oh yeah could you tell me about  freestyle rapping freestyle rapping [ __ ]  I wrote freestyle rapping doodle boat ah  yeah Zach uh-huh oh dude knew it I'm  never washing this hand again  Oh